porque es fundamental que estos tres
líderes mantengan sus encuentros
periódicos
para que la muchas gracias por la
invitación pues hay que iniciar diciendo
que esta reunión no se lleva a cabo
desde el 2016 es importante destacar que
la región de américa del norte es una
región muy competitiva y que en este
momento presenta pues grandes riesgos y
sobre todo grandes retos que los tres
jefes de estado tienen que analizar y
discutir es importante resaltar que
méxico tiene una relación bilateral
sumamente importante con eeuu pero
también con canadá así como estados
unidos una relación sumamente importante
con canadá así que es rescatable que el
día de hoy se reúnen los tres jefes de
estado aquí en washington mire y un tema
de gran interés para américa latina es
la realización en méxico de eeuu dado
que el país de andrés manuel lópez
obrador es el último paso en una de las
mayores rutas de migración ilegal del
mundo pueden los presidentes solventar
esta problemática y porque está lópez
obrador es supeditado al mandato
estadounidense en migración bueno a la
red es que méxico tiene en este momento
una serie de
retos que está enfrentando con eeuu más
allá del tema de la migración los tres
países están enfrentando el tema del cob
y 19 las cadenas de producción y sobre
todo también temas de seguridad en lo
que respecta al tema de inmigración yo
creo que lo que el presidente lópez
obrador va a plantear el día de hoy es
que es que apoya la iniciativa que hace
un par de meses envió el presidente de
bailén al congreso para poder legalizar
a los millones de indocumentados que en
este momento están en eeuu by the
necesita también de lópez obrador
necesita de lópez obrador porque
necesita que los migrantes ilegales que
vienen de centroamérica sean detenidos
en méxico entonces es digamos que una
relación que se necesitan mutuamente yo
creo que en ese sentido
washington va a ser y va a tratar de
trabajar de las manos con mexico para
poder detener esta cadena ilegal de
indocumentados también hay que decirlo
lópez obrador ha sido muy claro en el
sentido de que ambos países tienen que
invertir en la región tanto en el sur de
méxico como en el triángulo norte y creo
que aquí hay convergencias entre ambos
gobiernos
bueno y para el otro tema kobe 19 y
economía son 12 desde las grandes partes
de la agenda sabemos que la mayor parte
de la pandemia canadá se ha mantenido
hermético en sus fronteras cómo afecta
esto a eeuu es correcto bueno yo creo
que entre los tres países méxico es el
país que más ha presentado casos de kobe
en américa latina' el presidente de
lópez obrador desde un principio no
manejo correctamente el control de la
pandemia las vacunas llegaron tarde a
mexico y el número de casas ha ido al
alza yo creo que en este sentido eeuu
hubo un papel clave donando un número
importante de vacunas al gobierno de
méxico para hacer frente no hay que
olvidar las fronteras de los tres países
permanecieron cerradas hasta es un par
de semanas yo creo que eeuu lo que
quería era ver mejorías tanto en canadá
como en mexico para poder reabrir sus
fronteras el cierre de las fronteras a
productos y a personas no esenciales
evidentemente tuvo un impacto negativo
en el comercio entre los tres países y
yo creo que es fundamental que el día de
hoy se discuta qué hacer cuando haya
futuras pandemias al día y las tres
fronteras siguen abiertas ya están
abiertas y creo que lo que hay que
discutir es hacia futuro qué es lo que
vamos a hacer como región si presentamos
en un futuro una nueva pandemia